hey guys how's it going happy Veda which
is video every day in August usually
it's a blog every day but I'm not
vlogging every day but I am posting a
video every day and I am now sitting in
a red light but the light just turned
green so hold up wait a minute clearly
my priorities are are straight up to the
studio now we're doing a mocap session
with Activision and we're doing this
really fun project which will be coming
out very soon so excited for guys to see
the actual video we're here Francesca we
are here so I've definitely experienced
little mocap thing before but this is
the actual Activision black ops 3 Volk
app studio and it's way more intense
than the last couple that we've seen
they do like this crazy Elmo I can't
even you'll just have to wait to the
actual video to see it but this is
what's really fascinating is the face
mocap to get like expressions I wanna be
in a video game
I'm sure you could be like Kim
Kardashian in her app oh she just
so just an axis so map Sears giving our
pay cam so you can just talk straight to
this camera this is crazy
oh my goodness the things that I have
seen so Evan so I was I gonna leave you
guys a little sneak peek of what we did
today but I cannot wait for you guys to
see this video it's gonna be so awesome
anyway I'm going to meet Matt and Jenna
for dinner and then maybe I don't know
what's gonna happen
maybe we'll hang out play some Mario
Kart or who knows I really don't know
I'm not really sure I think I might want
to go home and play rocket League I am
so upset because I did not want to get
into this game and unfortunately I
decided to play it this morning and it's
really really really fun cause my baby's
going it's good that everything that I
filmed today I can't show them so now we
got to go do something cool this is
great because I've got big plans we sat
down and Jenna has the news camera ready
for me because I left her house what one
cam - cam we got lots of cams I screwed
up what Veda met video every day August
but it turns out means vlog every day
August I'm getting yelled at yesterday
why cuz I just uploaded called any video
no it's okay
after course I'm doing it as a video
everyday Joe Rogan
I'm not vlogging every day but yeah
mine too annoying onion-ring this is how
I eat a burger there is no way
what there is no way I actually do I
don't even read you can eat yeah that is
the most disgusting thing ever see a
really I don't like brown leaves Oh
ground beef to me
I've seen you do this before Palm
Springs yeah you're just eating new pet
I'm like
I'm disgusting I'm a hog Janna's who
will reward your go overboard overboard
Hoover Hoover Hoover Dam you know my
friend Huber oh my god
okay you're gonna give me the camera why
you did yeah I haven't I haven't done
this in a while
say no more yeah she's on homie Oh God
okay it's right it's hurting the tree
you are fine you got to just stand up I
got to do is get up a while in a while
oh this looks dope on this camera
Oh I whoa hello okay you run through the
six with your wolves right now what's so
soft on a carpet it is feels very soft I
can't get my bearings okay I can take it
back you got it Univ log now mm-hmm
hello look you're gonna long I'm gonna
vlog you're gonna vlog I'm gonna vlog
whoa whoa whoa have you hit anything in
here yet uh yeah you see that wall over
there
where oh right there I see it that's me
I Scout that up oh boy so uh we are
finished with dinner I can't I can't
even move so I decide again hey baby
baby baby the baby won't be baby I'm
going so slow
you know I tried to not order one but I
did and it'll be here next week so stay
tuned everybody because I'm not I'm not
happy about it but I tell you what it's
fun I'll just ride this one but you guys
are roving around okay I own this one
here my rope you're on no get on this
one get on this one oh no no are you
sure you weren't filming John I just
fell I fell again guys the same bruise
it's gonna be so much better
yeah I promise you on everything that I
believe in that I'm not making this up
for you too Jenna just fell again she
did Jenna do you guy that you do cuz you
were filming I turned it off we need you
to stop falling
I say it's looking from my body from the
last time I fell I can't feel my butt
when I'm with you cuz you fell on it
just fell in it so pretty up there
something like going outside with this
is a whole nother your until you're in
an environment a whole new indart I mean
there's like rocks
there's bomb honestly like for where
we're at if we're on the beach there's a
lot uneven ground
yeah oh it's not far-fetched to wear
like a helmet honestly right I will pass
I could go I've lost many brain cells
already had a butt pad I'm gonna need my
ha all won't use my other helmet okay
we're definitely wearing them I'm
getting you one oh I love helmets on I'm
all about safety on ants real that's
real stuff all about singing I'll get
you I'll get you on some blood for us so
freaking pretty
get so pretty we're getting Helms we're
getting Ellis I'm getting I'm getting
everyone at home
I think it's pink one because my Amana
Rovers could it be pink
I need a like a matte black matte black
helmet I on white and orange white and
orange well listen guys
Leoben and is do it differently dark
outside fold gonna go back to the one
Collette car it's cold difficult when
you're was late but I still do want to
buy gen come here and show my vlog your
but no I'm I'm gonna save it until it's
even worse than in show my blob on my
youtube channel all I've been paid it's
gross I saw it but I'm a little bruised
as well from the party anyway I'll see
you guys tomorrow
video every day August see you guys
later peace out what is it pal boom boom
boom boom pow pow